I know that you've recently been a part
of a developing a video game
um and it seems to me like it's sort of
a natural fit for a fantasy fiction
writer to work on a video game
how is that you know different from we
know you for working on
well it actually is considerably
different I've played some video games
I'm not a big video gamer
but the game is called the Eldon ring
and it's a sequel to a video game that
came out a few years ago called Dark
Souls and it came out of Japan
my work on it was actually done years
ago
um these games they're like movies they
take a long time to develop basically
they wanted a a World created to set the
game in they wanted a World building as
a big factor in in fantasy and science
fiction you're not only talking about
the characters in The Plot but you the
setting is almost as important
everything else tolkien's Middle Earth
Robert E Howard's hiborian age the
foundation Universe of Isaac Asimov I
worked up
you know fairly detailed uh background
for them and then they took it there
from there so you know I'd really it's
been several years since I've last seen
them but they would come in periodically
and show me some monsters they designed
or the latest special effects or uh the
cool things and but the game has been
very slowly developing and now it's
coming out in January I believe so I'll
be as excited as anybody else to uh to
see it so the Game of Thrones finale
aired two years ago this spring
um you know two years later how do you
look back and view that entire series
which became really a phenomenon it did
become a phenomenon it was the most
popular television show in the world for
a time it won more Emmys than any other
show in television history uh which is
uh those are both very exciting things
and I'm very pleased to be uh associated
with it and it also made me famous which
I have
um mixed feelings about
um I think it was uh Bill Murray who
said and if you dream of Fame and
Fortune try just Fortune first and
there's some there is something to say
that Fame is definitely a double-edged
sword
but
you know Westeros I've been writing
stories about Westeros and uh
the people who live there the Seven
Kingdoms since 1991 since I began that
it's such a huge part of my life at this
point and now I'm developing more shows
for HBO we have a new show House of
dragon that's uh coming down the pike
filming right now in in London and
Cornwall over in England
um probably Beyond next spring I guess
but then I'm developing other stories
for that so it's it's transformed my
life
you know for for good or for ill
um it is where I am and I do love
Westeros I love telling stories about it
um
so there's a lot more stories to tell